I always go into these things thinking
what if I what if I just have a total
brain fart yeah like you have no idea
what to say dudes so I saw that camera
there's there's um you see your eyes
goes like just make sure you're kind of
conscious of that do I want to be close
to turf no that's good yeah you're good
like that um you're at too weak now I do
a second one every other week so I'm
doing like six a month yeah definitely
definitely ramped up do you feel the
difference I guess that a big change um
yeah I mean it was like and it's sort of
like when you have one kid and that's a
lot of work and then you when you have a
second child you think it's it's gonna
be double the amount of work but it's
like five times imagine if this is sort
of like that I've been better about like
batching and systematizing what I do and
delegating and things like that so
that's good has it been that bad do you
most of them here in person I know you
some stuff like I said yeah I mean when
I travel like I take my stuff with me so
I do them on the road and then you know
sometimes people like I want to do it
but there's no way I'm driving to
Calabasas I'll make exceptions but I'm
trying to do them here as much as
possible so thank you for making the way
out here today I'm super excited to talk
to you both as I kind of post it on
Instagram the other day it just warmed
my heart to be at the screening of the
movie and to see two people that I care
for and respect deeply get together to
create something that's greater than the
sum of its parts
it's it was just such a cool thing
because I know each of you independence
of each other and then to see to people
that like I have so much respect for
like collaborate and make this amazing
thing it was just it was a really
special thing so I can't imagine what
it's like for you but I was really
honored to be at the screening the movie
is incredible and it's now out in the
world and that's gotta be an exciting
feeling for you guys yeah it's really
exciting for me
to point that out yeah I just don't want
to I don't want to get any credit from
my way for what was all Andrew well it's
a cool it's a cool story in that you had
not seen the movie until the premiere
yes
which put you in a precarious you know
sort of emotional state I would imagine
how was yeah how was that watching it
for the first time it was totally
surreal and overwhelming I I was sort of
prepared for it and sort of not and
sitting like in the fourth row with my
wife Kristen and then our kids and
something about the fact that my kids
went to the concession stand and had
like popcorn and candy somehow is one of
my enduring memories of looking down the
row at my family watching this movie
mm-hmm or my kids watching this movie
about their dad somehow it's like weird
the details but it had like this is your
life sort of thing yeah almost like an
out-of-body this is like if we showed
you this is where your life is going be
like no way right and you set up on
stage afterwards like like that's how I
sound and that's how I this is how it's
coming off like that feeling in the 80s
when your parents got an answering
machine and you as kids you're important
like hello you've called our house and
then you play a back and be like I'm at
like my sister of me like wait is that
what my voice sounds like this was like
a really big version of that yeah it's
so funny and and what's what's kind of
you know curious about it andrew is that
you kind of did this kind of quietly and
surreptitiously like you weren't
checking in with Rob like at one point
Rob you're like is that things still are
you and and you must have been when you
came on the podcast originally Andrew
you must have been in the midst of of
shooting at that time too and you didn't
mention any anything about it at that
time like you you seemed like somebody
who as an artist like really likes to
keep things under wraps until you're
ready to say anything about it yeah
that's a nice way of saying I think I
there's a lot of things that have fallen
through you know for me and I think
sometimes I've realized it's just better
to talk about it after the right and and
also also though I think there's
actually something this one is the most
private thing we've ever done and I
think
there was something when you talk about
it I think you give a little bit of it
away in a certain in a certain sentence
like for your own sake like this one was
very personal and it was very private
all the way up until the point that we
released it and it's yeah I like doing
it this way better having done it this
way
we've crowdfunded and other things
before that kind of requires you to be
right more upfront but um yeah this was
just a really I don't know just
creatively speaking this was pretty pure
this like independent financing no one
over our shoulder right no timeline
mm-hmm and yeah it that's it's a really
good way to make something yeah and it's
beautifully conceptualized and and and
put together I think it paints an
incredible portrait of Rob and who you
are as a human being and and the work
that that you do and the impact that
your work is having on the world and I
said to Andrew before you got here I was
I was like you watch the movie and even
if you had no idea who Rob is you leave
that movie with I think a pretty good
sense of what you're all about and the
impact that you're trying trying to have
you know it he he did really capture
your essence by following around those
many years you know and it's cool and I
think there's something about the way
the universe conspires to bring these to
manifest these types of things at the
perfect moment because we're at work
we're we're experiencing a very unique
period of time right now I mean just
last week as I'm sure you saw there was
that bizarre church that held that vigil
where people were wearing crowns of
bullets and they were sort of Herald
that people brought in their ar-15s and
and you know admittedly this is a very
you know fringe you know organization
but at the same time I couldn't help but
think how in some ways that perfectly
captures kind of what's going on
culturally right now where we have
conflated ideas around faith and
religion and the church and Jesus with
ideas that kind of swirl around the flag
and guns and nationalism I'm read a
fever pitch with this right now and I
think that that
of ghosts to the heart at many of the
things that you talked about mm-hmm
absolutely and if you think about human
development for thousands of years
there's the move from egocentric to
tribal centric but then the absolutely
necessary development from tribal
centric to world centric and in times of
great change or disruption or crisis or
trauma we as individuals there's always
the temptation will this pain break you
open so that you'll move to greater
inclusion complexity and depth or will
the pain cause you to regress to dig in
your heels and you're seeing right now a
lot of digging in yeah yeah you're
seeing right now a regression to tribal
ethnocentrism do you feel like that's a
natural you know part of the natural
process of eventually transcending that
yeah right I mean that that is the
question and the arc I mean the really
interesting thing about the arc of the
universe is it keeps moving forward
mm-hm that's the great mystery at the
heart of it all is particles forms atom
and atoms bond together and form
molecules molecules form cells like it
has a natural drive to an unfolding
unity weirdly enough underneath it all
so even even hearing about whatever that
church service thing is I'm sure your
listeners are like wait there's
something very wrong that's the wrong
direction mm-hmm so even in saying how
could they do that you're with your
gathering with millions of people going
and that's not where we're headed mm-hmm
I mean I hope not
right right right but we are seeing this
this you know reversion to you know
these ideas of nationalism and this kind
of reverence for our automatic weapons
yeah yeah and I sort of wrapping
ourselves in the flag as if that somehow
has anything to do with the truth behind
the Christian traditions and and what
just and like it's so bizarre and
confusing yeah and and the human heart
we want something to be sacred and holy
we we
depth we want a sense of wonder and awe
in our lives and what's interesting is
the gun for a segment of the population
has become the new unquestioned absolute
it's become the sacred thing and why do
you think that is uh I actually would
argue that America was birthed even the
story that we were in school about how
Columbus discovered America and you're
like was anybody already here yes mm-hmm
so yeah footnote footnote how have you
discovered something if someone's
already there yeah so in some senses the
narrative was skewed from the get-go
well you speak about this all the time
that history is dictated by the winners
by the winners this is the prism through
which right Rupert historical so we
quickly marginalized the people who are
here in some cases outright slaughtered
and then much of that early economy was
built on the backs of slaves and when
this tribe gathers to sing our national
anthem has the line bombs bursting in
air like when we sing of our unifying
myth we talk about bombs so we're about
4% of the world's population we have
something like 40% of its weaponry by
the way this is the nation with 750
bases military bases around the world
this is the one nation that has the most
mass shootings so there is a there is a
violence built into the whole thing and
it just keeps coming up and I would
argue that is the great thing that's
being unmasked mmm is the story has been
peace prosperity freedom democracy which
we're all for but it had to had an
underbelly of violence yeah there's this
percolating sort of you know
fermentation of dissatisfaction and
disassociation and frustration yeah with
a lot of people who you know kind of did
the right thing you know went to church
on Sunday and got the job and
went to college or whatever and and you
know climbed that corporate ladder and
arrived at a place only to discover that
you know to coin a phrase that you've
used in the past like maybe they put the
ladder up against the wrong wall like
right where's where's that sense of
peace and fulfillment and purpose that I
was promised and then when you're left
with that and you have been sort of
disillusioned by their traditions of
religion what do you what do you do
without energy right right and you have
lots of people who are witnessing to
this system didn't deliver what it was
supposed to deliver yeah even in when I
was traveling in the Bible Belt last
year in the deep south and and Andrew
was filming the send none of those
things are recommended yeah yeah you're
you just keep going back like you you're
all you haven't even gotten in
full-swing I'm the holy shift to her
right but you're still going down south
and oh we go all over yeah we go all
over but it was so interesting how many
people the up and to the right
understanding of things well you'll make
more money and you'll get more square
footage like as long as it's up into the
right it must be good the unquestioned
adherence an affirmation of more Amazon
can get it cheaper within two hours then
that must be good and people beginning
to question that story where many people
was the dominant story right and it the
kind of ladder analogy falls apart
because that implies that there's a top
rung but there's always another rung
once you get to that rung you're like
well I'm not feeling it yet but you know
that new Tesla is coming out next year
or whatever like there's always another
something to clutch at writing this is
the thing that's gonna solve that hole
in my heart yeah yeah and I love Abraham
Joshua Heschel
who marched with Martin Luther King this
legendary rabbi he said I didn't ask for
success I asked for wonder and then he
says and God gave it to me that what you
actually want is a sense of wonder and
awe you want to wake up in the morning
with a sense of
I get I get to do this that's actually
the thing that everybody wants mm-hmm
and we would will trade lots of things
for that so how do we how do we pursue
that
well it's interesting how many is how
many people when you ask them about
their life I'm struck with how many
people witnessed to a thread that has
been there from way back there's
something that was speaking to them the
whole time and sometimes like I have a
relative who if anything's broken he
becomes exhilarated because he gets to
fix it like just set him anywhere and he
comes to life when there's something
that needs to be mended I know people
who are healers you you you you show
them somebody with a broken heart and
they come to life
I know people who like I mean we could
go on this table I'm talking about
people we know who they've had a they've
been bent a particular way since they're
very very you know since way back mm-hmm
so I the most interesting thing to me is
just start asking people questions when
did you get most feel alive when have
you been caught up in something that you
lost track of time
what is something that when you do it
it's both exhausting but strangely
exhilarating you're tired but it's a
good tired mm-hmm what is it that when
you do it you think man I could do this
forever it's interesting how many people
can witness to some something I also
think that's a really hard question to
answer for a lot of yes yes we're so
disconnected right right no we've never
been asked that question yes even asking
people what they want how many people
lock up even at that basic question
desire as something that was supposed to
be repressed and sublimated for the
greater of something as opposed to no
seriously like what do you want and and
so how do you think about faith and
religion and and spirituality in that
context I always I begin with the whole
thing as a gift
and how you respond to it matters I
begin with gift you're here and
regardless of how your hearts been
broken and and how easy it is to roll
your eyes and fall prey to cynicism and
all the money you've lost in
relationships that fell apart something
within you this is a gift and you know
it that you're here in your breathing
mm-hmm so let's start there and how you
respond to it matters and despair is the
spiritual disease of yeah it doesn't
really matter
despair is tomorrow we'll just be repeat
of today none of it really matters or
despair can get manifest in in these
violent outbursts that we're seeing yes
exactly
regularity so I I I begin there and then
oftentimes it's the imagination if
despair is tomorrow will simply be a
repeat of today there's like a
disruption there's the invitation to a
disruption which is what if tomorrow
wasn't like today what if what if I mean
some people move into smaller houses so
they have less bills so they don't have
to work as much like I'll do that with a
live audience and people will laugh
really hard at that because I think it's
a joke but they'll laugh at that like oh
you're right it's amazing the amount of
people the amount of times I've done
stuff around that you know you could
work for the next 18 months and save and
then leave and go travel people do that
I mean I do it sort of like
tongue-in-cheek over-the-top but it's
amazing to the number people or you
could quit your job people do that
because they realize that it's actually
killing them
it's amazing number of people who quit
their jobs on the spot I see my batting
average I know you you you caused a lot
of people to quit ha ha ha you know I
did I did an event and a guy raised his
hand and he says ok I have a question he
says I'm a lawyer and I have this office
full of lawyers and I decided to expand
my law firm so we opened up a second
office two hours away and then I heard a
bunch of lawyers for that office so I'm
driving back and forth between the two
it says then I hired someone in charge
of Human Resources then I hired a CFO
and now we've got more cases more
clients more money coming in and I'm
feeling all this pressure I'm feeling
all this like sort of I got to keep this
whole thing going mm-hmm as I hold on
hold on who hired all the people he's
like I did I was like who decided to
open a second office I did who decided
to bring in a human resources director
and a CFO he's like I did
said do you feel like you're pushing a
rock up a hill he's like yeah I was like
who built the rock right he's like I did
there's like what what do you want what
kind of life do you want how many hours
do you want to work how many employees
do you want how many cases do you want
and what's so fascinating he's like I
don't know I never thought about it
mm-hmm it was like a reflexive just
build it yeah yeah because yeah it's
it's it's living it's in response to
just the the cultural mores of build and
grow and write bigger and you know and
and i would imagine even at times he
probably thought well if I hire all
these people then it will reduce the
load on me but ultimately it just
increases pressure and to me that's the
great gift of a tradition faith
spirituality religion ideally is it
create space where you can reflect where
you have village elders ideally who are
way older than you but younger at some
important level who can like help you
sift and sort what matters what doesn't
so I would say that those spaces where
you can ask questions and be asked
questions about your life and there are
resources and people who can say oh yeah
I've been through that mmm the
Solidarity of someone can be like oh
yeah I faced the same question here's
how I answered it I would start that the
most basic level with that mm-hmm Andrew
we're when did you first meet Rob and
what got you interested in yeah we met
my house it's a yeah it's interesting
it's really a shame listen you guys talk
I think we met three years ago at a
birthday party that her daughters were
daughters were 10 yeah and we started a
conversation and I was very very very
interested on a personal level I'd grown
up in a very conservative religious
evangelical place and I'd kind of grown
away from a lot of that and I think I
had really thrown my life into what I
felt like were some of the emergencies
happening on planet earth and I kind of
didn't care I didn't really have time it
I wasn't interested in things that felt
not important to that endeavor and at
the same time I think even my talk to
you last time rich I think I'd come
through a period of time where
I had begun to look at the world and
realize that there were some root causes
that kept bringing an enormous amount of
pain to the surface and there were some
things that if we were going to get
serious about really creating a more
just a humane beautiful future up ahead
that we couldn't just put band-aids on
like ancillary items we were going to
have to get serious about like what are
the stories what are the assumptions
what are the narratives that built this
world because it's not it's not working
it's not working soaring inequality
environmental crisis mental health
refugee crisis go down the list I think
as a person maybe it was part of it was
just kind of coming out of the arrogance
of youth like when you're really young
you think you haven't figured you know
anything so for me it was like well just
make enough sad documentaries and people
right the world will spin the other way
on its axis so I think what I was really
asking is what is it gonna take for
human beings to wake up mm-hmm and so
when I met Rob not only was it
interesting because of some of my
personal past and background I think I
felt like some of what he was
articulating some of the questions he
was asking cut to the very heart very
center of what kind of world are we
making and why mm-hmm and the damage of
some of those spiritual religious
faith-based stories is egregious and
continues to be and yet I think there is
a hollow Center if there's nothing else
if there's nothing pulling us towards an
openness a training on how we get
violence out of circulation uh a guide
to how I forgive people who have like
really hurt me those things that he was
articulate were just really fascinating
and as I started to follow him around to
a couple of events I began to realize my
story wasn't that rare that I think
there's a lot of people and by a lot I
mean like a lot a lot a lot of people
who grew up were handed some narrow
tradition it didn't keep pace with the
complexity of the world they found
themselves in and they they kind of put
it aside and probably rightfully so and
a lot of in a lot of things and yet
espied home says in the film they still
felt an ache they still felt a longing
for a space to keep them open to the
possibility of just how significant this
place is just how important this story
that were somehow mystically in the
middle of is like that was just really
fascinating stuff to me so I sat down
with Robin Kristin
just said I'd have never made a film
like this it doesn't really make sense
on paper but I'd like to film some of
the conversations that we've been having
I'd like to film the work you're doing
some of the people that you're doing it
with and then we'll see what it turns
into right see if they'll be a movie
yeah about knowing like going into you
know this this this unknown territory of
just like hoping something will happen
or a narrative will appear yeah and that
was like five years ago right
yeah that was like yeah yeah like three
three half years ago yeah and what's
interesting about that timing to rich is
that that was 2015 and in 2015 I think
and I it's interesting like like rock
you you're a very very optimistic person
Rob and that's amazing and that's I said
that night the familiar one the least
cynical people I've ever known and I've
benefited immensely from that but I also
think when we started filming that was
2015 and 2015 I think we all felt like
Obama was going to get a third term that
we were somehow on this like slide
towards the inevitable progress and some
not so subtle ways and then 2016 came
around and it was like I think all the
volume got turned up and I think we had
a fresh reminder of just how destructive
bad stories can be to the individual
human psyche all the way to the
collective life we have together and I
think it was at that moment that I I was
like I wanted to make the film and now I
know why we're making the film yeah I
mean set against the backdrop of what's
happening culturally right now it just
makes it it makes it extremely relevant
you know we're so divided and we're
confused about what's important and you
know that ache that that pee talks about
in the movie is very real and I think
you know all of us can relate to it and
whether we were brought up in the church
or with no tradition whatsoever we've
kind of bought into this cultural
Gestalt of of you know more more and
more and you know consumed our way to
bliss and happiness and when we find out
that that doesn't solve the wound and
we're left wanting and our heart is
yearning for something more where do we
look and I think that despondency can
grow out of that aura can mushroom cloud
into twisted notions of what faith is
all about that further divide us and
that's I think like the only upside of
that is that the the tremendous gift
this moment gives us is this kind of
fresh humility that we've come to the
end of a lot of stories like we've
played out several stories now the
consumer story the wealth bill that
built it bill that the success the even
some of the America story that's really
starting to show its cracks that's
that's profound because we've put a lot
of passive faith in those stories
serving us well and so to wake up to him
what we're like globally on the
environmental level that's not working
The Consumerist story leads us to a
horrendous end the way yeah me the way
we produce food maybe you go down the
line and I think that's the amazing
thing that's happening is we are like in
this world between worlds like we really
are still living in a world that was
kind of built like anything does a
revolution I mean like right like really
like our even our metaphors and our
assumptions like are still there they're
so out of pace with where we are and yet
some somehow we've lacked the collective
imagination to get serious about what's
next and you see on a variety of levels
like you know we have soaring inequality
we have an economic system that is even
the most fervent fans couldn't tell you
it paints a picture of a happy ending
and yet how much collective imagination
have we had about what we could do like
what we could create going forward and
part of my I think picking back up some
kind of spirituality came from this
place of realizing I think we need tools
that are better equipped to help us
imagine again and at its very best
that's I think what faith could do is it
could help us imagine hey we built this
world and for a lot of us we didn't even
built it we were born into it but like
when did we lose that sense that we were
here to make a new one like when did we
ever like stop you know I mean like I
just that that's the shift that you can
paint it negatively and I feel the pain
too I feel that I feel the negativity
right now too but there's also like
we've been waiting several lifetimes I
think to get to a moment where there was
enough humility around the table to be
like yeah it's not working mm-hmm we
don't have it
and so maybe now we could start again
yeah I think I think it speaks to the
lack of humility this idea that as human
beings we've got it all figured out and
we're living you know the pinnacle of of
what human civilization is capable of
which is clearly not the case and and
and I like that idea of being in an
in-between stage it's sort of like like
that like is a terrible analogy but like
like like early like like when special
effects just came online with movies but
they were really bad you know or like or
like the beginning of plastic surgery
you're like you know fifty years from
now it'll be so you won't be able to
tell but we're in that like in-between
zone where it's like yeah it's not
working very well you know and and it
and it's like what what it what what is
to come is uncertain you know and I
think you know stepping out to say
something about that is is what we need
right now and it's beautiful so when you
look at Rob like how does Rob speak to
these issues and and you know what is
Rob represent Rob and his work represent
to you in this conversation in this
dialogue well part of part of what I'm
and I'm I'm a little bit younger than
the two of you and I and I say that only
because I think one of the challenges
that people my age have had is we have
kind of come into the world in a sense
so like we've spent you know last decade
or two decades sort of deconstructing
our belief in almost every institution
which you know in some ways that's
pointing out corruptness that's saying
this didn't serve us well that didn't
work well and that has a lot of value
the downside to that is those
institutions represented our only
collective touchpoints so what that
means is you have a very whole
generation of people coming into the
world myself included that almost had to
navigate it like we were the first human
beings like and and the air of that was
kind of like when you look at the world
and all the things that we need to sort
out and all the things we need to it's
almost like we we had cut herself off
from any tradition we'd come from which
was good because a bunch of the [ __ ]
that we didn't want was gone but it it
severed us from looking back - has
anyone faced these questions before
mm-hmm has anyone had to
to figure these things that have human
beings been asking these so I think when
I met Robin and I started to experience
part of his work it was like that sense
of we need something to anchor us or to
route us more deeply if we're going to
be the people that grow more fully like
we're gonna need to borrow some ancient
wisdom here this isn't gonna just be
like a blog post and we fix climate
change this is gonna have to we're gonna
have to look back and figure out like
where where do these traditions come
from and what did they offer human
beings and in spite of all the bad and
all the outgrowth and all the you know
all the stuff that I think people
dismiss the whole thing with were there
tools inside of those things that could
still serve us now and I think that's
that's what I saw in Rob's work
initially was that sense of when I say
humility I mean for me as a person it
has been like I think we're gonna need
to look everywhere I think if we're
gonna solve some of the issues that
we're facing as a world we're gonna have
to look into places we haven't looked
before you know like I mean I think
we're living out right now it's like
we've we've looked at our national
political system as it's like that
that's not gonna be the end like come on
right now that's not going to get us out
of this place I think that's it's it's
super interesting what you just said and
I'm seeing it in other areas too like I
don't know if you've noticed like
there's this sort of heralding this this
celebrating of the traditions of
Stoicism lately that's now become like a
cultural movement like going back to
before and Rob you know you're somebody
who's painted as a progressive or a
Universalist or somebody who's putting a
modern spin on you know these ancient
traditions but that's not really what
you're doing what you're doing is is
you're going back to the beginning
before the institutionalization of all
of these ideas to get at the ideas
themselves yeah yeah and the word
radical comes from the Latin word radix
means root so radish is a root vegetable
the radical isn't the person who sort of
wandered off into the deep weeds the
radical is the person who goes back to
source who like goes back
goes back even farther hmm and
oftentimes what happens is these giant
traditions and institutions get built up
and then if somebody says wait let's
let's explore over here they're like oh
you're breaking code it's like no I'm
actually inviting us all to get back to
source and our original roots and so
many of these things you think about
well like second century Celtic
spirituality so this is 1800 years ago
at the center of Celtic spirituality was
proper care for the earth that there is
an inextricable bond between humans and
the soil and you protect that
relationship and you care for and
cultivate the land with an eye for
sustainability and loving care so a lot
of ideas and we kind of forgot about
that well what's funny is like a lot of
people a lot of ideas that appear like
mourn needed and whatever language
people use progressive etc so these some
of these I views are thousands of years
old I mean there's a line in the Psalms
about this book of prayers in the middle
of the Bible about how even in laughter
the heart aches
the non-duality of your heart mmm that
present within you at any moment is joy
and transcendence in euphoria an ache
and loneliness and anger and rage and
you are this fascinating even the very
simple binary how are you doing today
good or bad mm-hmm
thousands of years ago people were
witnessing to those simple categories
don't work when you're talking about
your interior life right and a lot of
people were raised in a world that had
gave them no tools for navigating their
interior life so you're just not at all
with you're just left with just push it
down just whatever you do push it down
but you have thousands and thousands of
years ago you have people saying prayers
and poems and songs trying to name these
debts because if you can give them
language then they don't haunt you if
you can drag them up then you're less
likely that what you submerge will
come out in some other way mm-hmm or you
think about like the Hebrew prophets one
a like the Hebrew prophet Amos this is
sort of Old Testament his big thing was
you have a widening gap between rich and
poor and that's gonna be bad for
everybody and when you have more and
more wealth in the hands of a few that's
going to be devastating for everybody so
every person who's ever said I'm with
Bernie I mean Bernie is channeling
whether you voted for him or agree with
all his policies when Bernie taps into
something and thousands of people go
there's something about that he's
tapping into two very ancient truths and
impulses all the Jesus story itself is
very much about that I mean I went to
your Christmas show yeah and I was just
like blew my mind I was like yeah I went
to church but like I don't really know
that much about it and when you kind of
broke down the historical context in
which this story arose and and why you
know in your opinion it became so
timeless and potent and then tied that
to what's going on in our current
culture right now it's like shocking the
the parallels absolutely you Christmas
is the ultimate I love that doing that
Christmas show because Christmas is such
a neutered sort of you know we give
presents and apparently there might be a
nativity scene although Fox News a lot
of story about how a tree and a guy and
record guy and like what does that have
to do with right this is pregnant Jewish
teenagers on the run with the boot of an
empire on their neck mm-hmm and the
birth of a new kind of King was a
political threat to the current king
they believe that Galilee in the first
century taxation rates were somewhere
around 90% I mean you and you have a
whole history of revolt during that time
it was a politically volatile time and
there was a dominant narrative of Empire
which was peace through victory just
basically crush everybody the Roman
Empire crush everybody doesn't agree
with you it's peace to victory because
everybody who opposed it is dead and
this story had per ticket so the
original Rage Against the Machine it is
I mean this story was a loaded
socio-political economic counter
narrative
but yeah I mean talk about radical
revolution salutely speaking truth to
power and somehow that story got
co-opted by Empire which is insidious I
mean a lot of people talk about the
fourth century
in the fourth century the Emperor
Constantine essentially co-opted the
Jesus Movement and sort of ie people
have people find this compelling okay
then I'll take it and sort of co-opt it
for my own political purposes and a lot
of people point something really deep
because this Jesus movement was share
your possessions have a common meal make
sure everybody's rent is paid
sacrificial love is how the world is
made better and your connection with the
earth with each other with yourself with
the divine but right away then right
after that you have the birth of the
idea of original sin which was that
people are first and foremost wretched
and depraved as opposed to those an
inherent goodness that every human being
has a dignity and a divine imprint that
regardless of what they've done they
still bear that that's a holiness and
sanctity to every single person do you
respect them and look out for them as
you'd look out for yourself like you
think about how many things in the
fourth century and people say well
that's just religion that's just sort of
primitive those strands get people
elected in 2016 I mean they're still
wafting in the air yeah it's it's uh
it's crazy I mean this is the you know
the one of the big lines in the movie
where you say you know I honestly
believe that if Jesus was alive today
and he would be you know I don't know
exactly mortify religion in his name
yeah but then when you turn on the
television and you see people draped in
flags and carrying guns and they're
aligning this with some kind of right
you know religious tradition it's just
it's like somewhere along the way we
have lost our way completely completely
completely and if you think about the
Jesus Movement it was birthed out of
there is a shared humanity that every
way that you can cook up to divide
yourselves there is a shared
common humanity that you have with every
human being mm-hmm that overrides that
and so you listen to that it's like you
keep your ear bent towards that mm-hmm
and if there's anything at the heart of
the Jesus story it was always the
inclusion and the universal embrace of
all people everywhere so the idea of
some sort of all these people are in
these people are out these people have
favored these people I don't know about
them it's just completely contrary to
the story hmm
so Andrew you go on the road with Rob
and travel all over the place watch him
speak you you interview you know some of
his amazing co-collaborators there's
Pete Rollins and Pete Holmes and who
else is interviewed in the movie we have
a little bit of a story I'm on the road
though is it good yeah one motel it now
where and I want to say Charlotte North
Carolina because there Andrew keeps his
cool like oh he just he's amazing he
just keeps it mm-hmm but he came
bursting into the green room right
before I was gonna go on like with this
like child at Christmas like oh man oh
man all right and I was like what is it
and he's like we have friends and I was
like we have friends and he looks at me
and he's grabbing like an extra camera
as he rushes out of the green room and
he says protesters yeah it's like
filmmaker gold I was like is this like
in your world is that like gold and he
oh he was like there was like this big
gift to him that there's somebody out
front with a bullhorn yeah and you see
those that you see that in the movie
that that's from that event I mean and
you told me this prior you know like
yeah there's people that protest me when
I go and speak and I was like I can't I
thought maybe a couple people standing
out front but I was like no those those
people mean they meant business no joke
you know so so tell me where they're
coming from and what they represent man
that's a good question it's really
strong it's stronger than I knew when I
first met Rob there is um yeah people
are people aren't happy about what he's
doing
I mean an enormous group of people are
but yeah there's
there's a really strong contingent and
it cuts right to the core of who they
are and how they see the world I mean I
think it's I think ultimately more than
anything else I think what Rob's
challenging is he's challenging a sense
of what he just said insiders Outsiders
us them were right they're wrong I mean
that has been the tremendous conclusion
of a lot of religion is that we're right
we found the answer and these people
over here haven't and I think to even
begin to articulate something that's
more inclusive than that is profoundly
offensive to people because I think
religion for a lot of people does
simplify a really maddening complex
world we find ourselves living in you
know its columns its categories it's
black it's white and so I think when Rob
comes along and says there's a whole lot
more color in this picture and let's
just be honest about the fact there's
also stuff we don't know no view and I
died and kind of instead of instead of
when challenged by that idea to say oh
yeah maybe we should look at that the
response is rather to to be aggressively
dismissive and label him the heretic
there is a quote I don't really forget
who said this but it was it's not a new
quote at all but someone said whenever
human beings are are unsure we become
doubly sure and there's that sense in
which the areas in our life that were
most that are most vulnerable were the
most like strident and the way we just
you know I'm saying so when I look at
people holding a megaphone screaming
their guts out about Rob saying homeless
can get into heaven
I just think man there's a lot of
there's actually a lot of pain in there
like there's actually I actually spent
time I remember just in the edit suite
just kind of like you know you look
through things slowly and just looking
at some of their faces and thinking I
don't you know my I have little kids at
home like I don't think I don't think
any of us come into the world with that
kind of vitriol you know I don't think I
don't think any of us show up on the
scene and like had this impulse to and
the other thing that I think Rob really
offends people on and I think the
strongest reaction we've had so far the
film to the negative is that I think it
actually surprised me but most of it has
with America and that's true of work
I've done before - it's like when you
touch America you touch something really
deep and and when Rob criticizes the
fact that we've put the flag in the
cross side by side - really horrendous
consequence real human history
especially recently in this country
that's that's that's strong for people
and I think what it is and I think it's
it's going back to somebody said earlier
which I think it's what's happening
right now in America big time it's
happening so fast we can't even handle
it is that when you pull the cross away
from the flag you take off that thin
veil of moral superiority or whatever it
is we had and you just left you're left
with very naked nationalism you're left
with a sense of like that we're in
they're out we're right they're wrong
like think about that yeah without the
the ability to morally justify it yes in
that way suddenly it just becomes really
offensive and I think no one wants to
feel like they're wrong
and I mean I think about that on any
level you know I think about that with
reactions people have the you private
experience to like what people eat yeah
it's I mean I mean it's not quite as
vociferous as religion I mean there's
nothing as as certain as sort of you
know heightened as that but but yeah you
see it in the diet debate Wars where you
know the people that are the least
informed are the ones that dig in the
deepest and are the loudest and there is
that question I mean there is that
question and and one of my primary
sources of intrigue with Rob has been
that question as I said earlier how do
we wake up because we're in desperate
need of human beings waking up on this
planet and why do some people experience
something and move to a later stage of
consciousness and why do other people
not and I don't know the answer to that
I really don't know the answer to that
so you see certain people that I watch
certain people engage with Rob's working
to some people it's a very
life-affirming and it's very it opens
them up it moves them forward to a place
of and and to other people that's just
that's just really really offensive
stuff and to me to me that is the great
question if you're a person of faith of
any kind I think the great question
right now in front of all of us even if
you're not in religion the great
question is how and 2018 as a person can
you be
like someone who holds belief that moves
them towards really hope filled action
and yet be open to when new information
contradicts that belief I mean that
that's I mean I think about that with
climate change a lot because I think a
lot on the environmental spectrum I
think about the people that deny that
and I just think about from a business
standpoint like whenever you've backed
your life into a corner what you said
earlier like it's not like we've arrived
but there's a lot of us who were kind of
given that view of the world like I was
sort of raised like that like here's
human history like do to do to do and
then now we're here and we did it right
right so like is is your faith is your
religion is your tradition is your lack
of religion something that opens you up
to the possibility that ten years from
now I might be sitting down here with
you rich and I might have I might be
able to look back and be like well I
would hope that you would say that if
you are if you are if you do have
fidelity to that idea then you should be
saying that at that time right so so
yeah it I think it goes back to on
wonder if you can if you can live in
that place of awe and wonder then you're
you're you're open to change a
possibility and you're not hardened by
your dogmatic belief about X Y & Z and
it requires a certain humility to do
that it's very threatening for a lot of
people so when Andrew says Roblin Andrew
says you know I don't know why some
people can be provoked and you as a you
know sort of quote-unquote you've been
called a provocateur you know to sort of
provoke people to think a little bit
more broadly or out-of-the-box about
some of these ideas what do you think
the difference is between somebody who
can hear that and and go back and
recalibrate versus the person who digs
in right right well this is the this is
the thing that happened in the modern
world is you had the birth of the
machine and the machine was built on
causality a plus B equals C so if you're
gonna build a flat-screen TV or an
airport you're going to take apart
creation to understand how it works
they're gonna put it back together in
particular arrangements but that's built
on you need to know that these atoms are
going to do
there's a predictability into
probability there and so for many people
and then you think about Newton's
Principia and mechanical laws of physics
the universe operates according to some
rules apples fall from trees at a pretty
consistent speed so we were like seeped
in this view of the universe that there
are these laws and predictability 'he's
that undergird everything and the
problem is for many people the modern
world that thinking spilled over into
matters of soul and spirit so for many
people when you get into the infinite
the divine that which you can't access
with your five senses buts more real
love grace forgiveness loss that which
you can't access with the assumption for
many people is well it must work that
way as well hmm well this idea that that
science and faith are mutually exclusive
and that we've transcended these these
sort of antiquated ideas of faith for
this newtonian you know yeah of right
how the world really functions right and
you know a couple observations about
that i mean i think i heard you say one
time that's all fine and good until you
know that hardened newtonian you know
physicist or whoever you know hand it
holds our baby for the first time and
that sense of awe and wonder and
possibility and impossibility kind of
enters that person's awareness in a new
and different way right and and beyond
that this idea i just lost my train of
thought but it had something to do with
i'll get a vacuum it was so eloquent it
was amazing yeah the future well this
idea of reconciling reconciling like
science and faith right and and and
making room for that which is beyond
like i don't see them as mutually
exclusive like the more you learn about
science the more insane it is like the
more possibility i see for absolutely
exceeds our ability to comprehend and
the best scientists are the ones going
and then we learned this which raised
all these new questions well i think of
them we can answer and some of them were
like
we don't know yeah we don't know and
that that's the humility part but I
think with science comes that lack of
humility this the sense that as human
beings were capable of figuring
everything out and that we can we can
understand it it's only a matter of time
before we can write we can pin this down
on paper and perhaps our brains are not
evolved to be able to see what is maybe
right in front of us had we had another
lobe on our head you know some other
sense that we don't know what it is you
know but but our hubris tells us that no
that can't be the case right right so if
you go back to what happened for a lot
of people is the assumption was that
human consciousness must work like
everything else like show me where the
buttons the levers and the machinery is
and then we'll get everybody farther
along but you to you uh you take two
different people and you two people
struggling with alcohol and you do an
intervention with both of them in their
living room and the one says thank you
so much
you guys love me this much and the other
one says after you get out of my living
room in very similar circumstances
why do Fred know those guys but think
about your friends think about even in
recovery why do certain people go I
can't do this for one more day and
somebody in various your other friend
yeah I'm fine everything's fine denial
avoidance it's the great mystery at the
heart of the whole thing they're these
great parables Jesus tells like he tells
one parable to his disciples it's almost
like he's talking to this crowd and he
it's almost like he leans over to the
disciples is that okay here's the thing
I'm gonna say some things that are true
and some of these people they're gonna
wake up and see it and some are gonna
want to kill me it's as if they're it's
as if I'm hanging out I'm passing out
seeds that some of this ground is really
hard and rocky and some of the ground is
like fertile on the seed is going to
take root it says if a number of Jesus
stories are as if he's about I don't
even understand how it works I don't
even understand why I do know that we
generally need pain to wake up yeah or
some experience in which our current
categories and labels are no longer
sufficient so the number of people I
mean you think about them
how many people were taught something
about let's we're taught that is
something ridiculous like all Muslims
are violent or something and then a
Muslim family moved in next door and
they're like the best neighbors they've
ever had
all of those previous categories of
organizing things fall apart in that
moment and you either entrench dig in
your heels and fight it or you let it
break you and take you into new places
mm-hmm and that's the endless invitation
you think about post 9/11 the trauma of
losing all these Americans in this
horrific attack and you essentially had
collectively almost two responses the
one response was why do you people not
like us why why are we the target of
this sort of terrorism where I Trade
Center why a Trade Center which doesn't
deny the evil atrocity of killing
innocent but just says okay what is the
larger thing at play here is there
something about us building military
bases on other religions holy sites that
aggravates people have they been saying
could you please not build military
bases on our holy sites and you have a
whole series of new questions being
asked about the role of this tribe in
relation to other tribes the other
response to 9/11 if you could caricature
it would be these colors don't run
crank up the Toby Keith we're gonna put
a boot in your ass and you can see it
collectively you can see then visually
you can see it when a friend of yours
loses someone they love and it's just
ripped their heart out and some people
become more open more tender that loss
they become a friend to everybody who's
lost somebody they love like they look
them in the eyes and say me too and then
we have other friends who lose somebody
they love and they become bitter small
they're still shaking their fists at the
universe about why this happened it's
it's the great mystery but what we can
do and and the real invitation I would
say now which we saw in the past
election the real warning is not to let
your enlightenment become an obstacle to
the enlightenment of others what do you
think what we happened is we've had this
narrow bitter brittle right exemplified
by all the Fox
newse jokes ever heard but what happened
in our culture is a the left a narrow
brittle judgmental left has emerged and
but that one's even more insidious
because it has an underbelly of
arrogance because it's not the right and
I think for a lot of their further
aggravates the right and entrenches it
absolutely yeah absolutely and and
resentment is just lethal to the whole
thing and I think a whole world of
educated intelligent accomplished people
sent a message from the left to the
right if we get it we're gonna make the
future there's gonna be driverless cars
in no time I know to half a million
people get their jobs from driving
trucks but you'll be out of a job in no
time just give us give us an uber a
moment and we'll sort that out and the
real spiritual question hanging in the
air is can you listen to where that
resentment comes from and then I think
the the failure of the left I think is
the thing like think about election
night how many people on TV were like I
didn't see this coming
yeah I didn't see this coming and a guy
in a tower not a metaphor you mean gold
tower with kingly xiv but it to me was
so interesting is he heard something
which and his wife said if you run
you'll win so he saw and heard something
that the most educated accomplished in
the know folks didn't hear oh yeah he
was so that's interesting
he was a perfect tuning for absolutely
tap into you know absolutely that world
of people who feel hurt and on her right
and to me the great spiritual question
is the absolute necessity of listening
to how does this system not work for you
to such a degree that you would pull the
pin on that option mm-hmm you don't I
mean that's to me like the great
spiritual challenge of our day is
how does this system so leave so many
people feeling out left out and whoever
you are you have a vested interest in
that because everything is intimately
connected with everything else mm-hmm
and I think that's the really
interesting thing that's happening now
is you have all these people going I
think I missed something which goes back
to the humility I think I missed
something about the way this thing works
and that can only lead us in better
directions yeah and I think you know
using that tuning fork analogy like you
you're a tuning fork for that for for
that division like that the protestors
show up and then the people who are sort
of vibrating on that frequency are the
people that want to hear you speak and
both crowds you know appear when you
arrive and that's got to be you know one
of the things in the movie you know
knowing your story I didn't fully
appreciate the the level of of courage
it takes to kind of step into this
message that you're putting out there
knowing that it is provocative and that
for certain people indigestible
and yet understanding that it's your
truth and doing it anyway at great
personal risk to yourself like when you
told that story about what it was like
when you left Mars Hill because it's
just what you felt like you had to do
and started trying to you know reinvent
how you were communicating with the
world and seeing how people were a lot
of people were not happy about that and
then less people were showing up to hear
you talk oh yeah but like sort of
remaining true to that like that's
that's uh that's a Warrior's path yeah
it felt like a long sole evolution in
the same direction like I just kept
following it where it led but yeah what
was it what was going on like take me to
that moment oh yeah yeah at Mars Hell
where you realize like I can't this is
not my path
well I had krysta and I started a church
when we were 28 and it got very very
very big and it was amazing I got to see
amazing things I got to participate and
it was incredible but I also had this
growing sense that there's no way when
you have an institution that's that big
that doesn't become about preserving and
protecting that Institute like we got to
keep the church running and my interest
was not in keeping an association
running it was creating a space where
everybody from every background could
access the spiritual depth of life so it
was like oh I have to keep going and
what I started touring I started doing
like Club theater tours in 2006 so I
started touring like a bamboo tour like
tour bus and doing like these one-man
shows
and I that felt like home like talking
about how everything is spiritual and
the spiritual depth of life in public
spaces was like that's where you'd hear
your favorite comedian your favorite
band it was like this is where we should
be talking about these things not over
in the corner my interest wasn't in a
particular group of religious people
over here my interest has always been
and what's it mean to be human yeah yeah
you say sorry I don't mean to interrupt
you but you kind of tell this story in
the movie where you say you know you're
you're a young person and you were a
church and you had a very visceral
realization oh yeah young age like this
is the stuff of life like whatever
they're talking about up here like this
is this is the most important impactful
magical mysterious beautiful subject
matter that a human being could ever
entertain because it is about yeah what
it means to be human and yet why am I so
inspired right why is this so honest for
this should be the most inspiring thing
ever right right right right we as human
beings and especially like your
listeners who say they're not religious
then don't show me your photos from
Burning Man because you want meaning you
want depth you want connection yeah
burning Burning Man is it is a response
to that
that's yearnings
absolutely so we are fundamentally
spiritual religious creatures we are
desperate for meaning significance and
depth like that's the juice of the whole
thing so I just didn't buy some of the
categories from the get-go and when
people say well that sounds kind of like
you're talking about spirituality yeah
cuz you are too because we all are all
the time this thing is what are you
gonna do with this gift where does it
come from what's it mean where it's
headed
what's it mean to be or what's it mean
to be me so yeah I just had this
chrisser and I kept having this sense
well I happened very quickly
oh with this chapter is over and I need
to keep going and just keep doing what
I'm doing to follow it where it leads
and this chapter with a local church
there was a great chapter but I have to
keep going and take it far and talk
about these things in spaces where
somebody who would never go to church
could stumble into this and be like oh
thank you yeah I needed this right this
is helpful so that's how it worked but
then what happened I did a tour right
after right as I was leaving the church
and I put out a book called Love Wins
and that was fairly divisive so I did a
tour that far I just glossed right over
that to err like nobody should I mean
there were there were cities where I
would do like a 1500 seat venue and I'd
you know it had been sold out the last
time I came through and like 71 people
would show up and I'd be in the green
room getting ready to go out and the
promoter come back and be like yeah
pretty empty house out there and you'd
walk out in this cavernous room and it'd
be like a couple people and and I
remember one guy saying yeah on your
previous tours we put the tickets up and
vans if Church people would buy those
tickets I would be sold out in no time
and now there none of those vans are
coming pariah and all I knew I just knew
apparently that particular subculture
isn't listening but I knew there are
millions of millions and millions of
people who are more hungry than ever so
it's like all you have is this deep
abiding
trust believe hope conviction that no no
there are millions of people who want to
talk about this stuff mm-hmm and that
just keep going just keep going but that
tour was and I remember that to her
because I couldn't afford two of us and
I remember like going to the rental car
place it drives like eight hour drives
every day and I remember that like I
couldn't have I was losing money so this
friend of mine who's like a large man he
was like with me I remember we had to
get like the cheapest rental car so
we're in a Ford Festiva we're lost
somewhere in Virginia I'm driving along
like wonderful anyone can show me into
California we're starting this new life
there are no guarantees all you know is
you have the sense that you just have to
keep going but you never question that
sense no because I and in the film I
joke about Kristin and I talking about
well he could always sell shoes yeah
a spinal to have a reference I knew I'd
rather maybe this maybe this all dries
up and I'll go do something else but at
least I'll have my integrity
I still have my soul which i think is
what which which I think honestly is a
huge part of what I was interested in
the film is I think that a lot of us are
we don't have enough examples of people
who are on a path and stick with it and
I think it has cost something you know I
think it's cost more than you even take
take note of sometimes rather maybe
that's like a gift that you but denial
is my drug of choice but it's but it's
kind of in mine too
it's kind of incredible to witness and
that's like there's the work itself that
you're doing but there's also like your
life signify something for people
because I think a lot of people
listening to a show like this I think
they are there's a cost if you're doing
something purposeful and intentional in
the world
you don't just drift there you know I
mean rich you're that way your story's
lined with that like yeah I so I'm
fascinated by that from a from a story
standpoint because that is the thing
that good stories are made of and it's
the thing that really interesting lives
are made of you know I mean so it's cool
to witness that because it's like Rob
can just kind of keep going in the face
of all of it but it is you line up ten
other people and I don't think they all
would have kept going
but no it's it's very Joseph Campbell
but like I'll be in a doing this to wear
all year long the holy shift to her I'll
be in next weekend is Sacramento San
Francisco Santa Cruz it's like a three
city run next week
I'll walk out and say thank you I'm so
glad you all are here I'll mean it to
the very depths of my bones like I I
have a gratitude at the end of the night
when I always just thanked the audience
you never know it's like to show up at
miles from home and you all were here I
mean that in a way I could never begin
to explain to the ground it's such a
wondrous no way I get to go out and do
this again I think I'll give like this
holy shift to her I'll give us talk like
50 times this year and I'm headed into
the tee I'm like a number nine ten or
eleven now and I'm more humbled and
thrilled to do it yeah how many talks
here do you give haha oh not that well I
do like I do like like a sermon sort of
thing from my podcast yeah so that's
probably there's a bunch of those then
there's like a few there's a few of
those then I do these events where I
talk for two days straight to do eight
hours a day for yes so this is the thing
that I'm getting at in like Andrea I
know you you agree with me on this I
mean Rob you're you're a very gifted
master communicator like you have an
incredible acuity for connecting with
audiences and individuals and and a
facility for I don't know tapping into
something primal that connects people to
whatever it is you're trying to say and
it's it's powerful you know III don't
see it there are certain other people
that I see it in your certainly one of
those people is this something you've
always been able to do like you're so
comfortable onstage you just you have
such a command over what you're doing is
it always but have you always had that
or obviously it gets better the more you
do it I was in a band in college and I
was the front man
never I'd never sung but I was like the
front and I was like some version
somewhere between Talking Heads and Red
Hot Chili Peppers and Violent Femmes
yeah and midnight oil is that on the
internet anywhere you know what
apparently it is well andrew you had to
dig up everything for the movie right
you got it so so put me writing songs
and sharing them I was like Oh times
never that good but when I did that I
was like oh I don't know if I'm any good
at this but man it feels like coming
home and then when I discovered the
sermon and realized the sermon was an
art form that had been hijacked did you
say the word sermon and most people are
like and what's for lunch mm-hmm I mean
I'm sure your listeners the word sermon
is like anything but a sermon but then I
would say but hold on Martin Luther King
I have a dream that was a sermon it was
beautiful and dangerous and subversive
and poetic and it was economic and
political was about the heart and about
our shared life together and it was
unsettling and healing and disturbing
the comfortable and comforting the
disturbed and no one heard that sermon
and went I don't know he was funnier
last week you mean like like so we sort
of roll Erised the sermon and yet what
you have heard some you know of some
sermons that were like events they were
guerrilla theater meets performance art
you know so what happened in my early
20s is I stumbled into this art form and
was like I am gonna resurrect this art
form for everybody so that's what
happened is well you've really cut
you've claimed it and we need to find it
I mean like I listened to your podcast
and I just I'm like first of all I'm
like how does he just talk into the
microphone and like do this incredibly
eloquent forty-five minutes like I don't
know how that works but beyond that like
I don't think of it as a sermon right
it's just a variant these are like your
insights you know all right
whole variety of things but then when
you're like yeah that is a sermon it's
like alright well what is a sermon
exactly like - I take ownership of that
until like invert it and claim it as
your own in this new expression I think
is and I remember I remember at the
beginning when I started doing sermons
is like I either call this something
different because of how many people
just want to throw that up in their
mouth at the thought of a sermon or I
double down on it and I like by sheer
force of will just keep saying servant
I force until you're forced to fake it
it's literally like you either you
either shy away from it or you just go
no they got it wrong this is what a
service yeah I really love it I I love
it more than ever I downloaded your
program something to say oh yeah and I
listened to it over the course of a
couple long that was eight hours yeah I
know like two or three [ __ ] two or
three training rooms nine hours that's a
run that's I know but I was like wow you
really break it down like I was like how
can you talk about this for eight hours
I was like oh my god like I have to
listen to it again because I was just
riding my bike I was sort of you know it
was percolating in my consciousness but
like I actually want to take notes and
write it down really powerful primer on
like look if you if you want to express
yourself if you have an idea like let me
give you a roadmap to put your best foot
forward so that you can yeah create the
best version of whatever it is basic
syndicating yeah yeah I try wanted to
create forever but if someone has a blog
somebody just has to give a speech to
their employees somebody has to give
something motivational to the team I
wanted to create something for everybody
who's got something I need to
communicate to give them as many tools
as possible but you would love I've been
doing these events where people come and
bring whatever they're working on I'm
gonna do that and get some kind of so
I'm kind of stunned we talked about this
before little stuck you've extended
yourself to like help me through that
and I'm gonna tell I'll get you unstuck
yeah so yeah it's like you know I think
this this kind of dovetails into what
Elizabeth has to say about you like you
guys are like you know you have this
really cool kind of brother-sister
relationship but you're both creative
powerhouses and it's about creative
expression it's about how do you
communicate your ideas in a compelling
way
she's Elizabeth Gilbert is unbelievable
and she and I were on this tour with
Oprah Winfrey I would say Oprah Winfrey
in case
but I'm not the other for Elizabeth and
I started doing these q and A's and
where we would just go out into the
parking lot and we would just sit on
stools and take questions and she brings
she would bring these like four
paragraph answers that were just
mind-blowing she and then later she put
out a book called big magic yeah and I
was like oh no wonder she was crushing
the key with it she could without
writing a book but somebody the things
she was saying are in that book she's
she is truly an extraordinary community
just what she has to say and how she
says it
I'm speechless so Andrew when you're on
the road with Rob like when you you know
how how did it differ from what you
expected like what did you take away
from that experience that perhaps was
different than what you imagined it with
you I don't think I imagined just how
much because you're right I mean like if
we're if we're being honest like Rob has
a very very high ability in some of
these areas you know and not everybody
has that ability maybe not even that
capacity and he's kind of like
performing at the top of his game and I
think what's fascinating is when when
I'm with him he continues to have like
that posture of a student and he's
continually like fascinated by the whole
thing like he's just learning how to do
it
and he continues to it's not just the
like I read three books before a
breakfast thing it's also just the the
posture of like isn't this interesting
like what am i what am i learning in
this moment which is I think I've been
around people before who are
communicating from a place of certainty
empower anyone who's been in a church
has seen that and it's almost that thing
that you alluded to of like I figured it
out and I want to let you know versus
there's just this sense when you're
around Rob and everyone that knows him
says this it's like this orbit because I
told one time I was like when I when I
leave you when I spend time with you and
I leave and I go back to my life I find
myself loving my life more like it's
somehow like everything's gotten like
more vivid like something about like and
I think that's just that just comes from
the fact that he is a person who is
immensely
like all the stuff that he's talking
about isn't from a place of like I
figured it out now and I'll let you know
it's like curiosity genuine curiosity
and also just a lack of cynicism and a
lack of fear I mean to be honest like
you said that rich about like you know I
think Rob can sort of like navigate
around a lot of the critics and the hate
but just doesn't make a decision from a
place of fear and like that's a pretty
cool thing I mean like when the election
rolled around and he texted me and said
I'm gonna go do a series of speaking
events in the deep south called the
Bible Belt or
it was like it seems ill-advised but
good for the movie I loved having Andrew
along because I loved being like do you
see that what you think about that like
income what would be an example of that
here well I'll give you an example that
I'll give an example that Rob's doing a
Rob's really accessible a lot of these
events and so afterwards in Ohio
yeah right this is Ohio is that right is
it how a guy comes up Rob's doing a book
signing because this portion was like
with the book the publishing company had
set him on this little book tour so here
this book story this guy you know a lot
of love people giving him hugs
appreciating him he's signing books
taking pictures and this guy comes up
and he like slams down this thing on the
table and he's like I'm making a
documentary about you he's waited in
line I don't agree with you and I'm
giving like it's almost like a subpoena
he's like this is your one chance you
deserve you've been sir it had that vibe
and and I opened it up the but it's like
what's amazing is like I know a lot of
reactions to that and like Rob laughed
for like 30 minutes about that you can't
make that stuff up it's this thing I
think this is what it is there's an ax
there's an amount there's a dose of joy
and and and to be honest I mentioned
this even at the premiere I think there
was even a season there we're coming off
the election and the dismantling of the
EPA and all these things that are really
upsetting to me I almost I almost
resented it for a minute like there was
almost this thing of like it was a
hauling problem is more serious than you
think like there's real stuff huh and I
think what I experienced think I'm in
Ohio today
I think what I experienced was that
sense of like it's so serious like it's
so heavy that it also is it's that you
talk about the light heavy light that
there's a light on the other side of him
heavy and I think that's the I think
people wouldn't expect that amount of
joy in the midst of articulating some of
these ideas that are not not always like
yeah and I mean Rob is that something
that is not just part of your
Constitution or do you have to cultivate
that sense of joy and levity and on
Wonder and curiosity and optimism or
yours bake that way I'll probably bake
that way but what I kept noticing is the
people who came in who came in hot with
a case to make something within me
whether it's an evolutionary impulse
what sort of reptilian brain something
within me braces when I feel like
somebody's coming in to show me I you
know II mean there's like a heaviness
that they need to let me see how seer
there's something within me just braces
myself mm-hmm and that I just noticed
the people who it's like they were
dancing it's like they were hearing
music that I couldn't hear yet
it was like an element of seduction I
did this actually when the turning
points is I did an event with Bishop
tutu and Dali Lama hmm and I was
expecting it to be heavy ass like these
- this is gonna be heavy
I mean they just crack each other up
Bishop tutu with Truth and
Reconciliation is this person went into
this village with a machete in 1994 and
slaughtered everybody in this person's
family but them now the person's going
back to the village to apologize for
killing their whole family and this
person forgives them publicly and
there's documented evidence where they
then become friends so that's what he's
been doing
Bishop Dalai Lama when people are like I
got some haters on Facebook Dial Amma
has some haters China you know I mean
like he has he's been on the receiving
end so so these people who these people
work at a is is there a higher or deeper
level and they walk into the room from
opposite sides of the room and they meet
right in front of me and they hug each
other and they start tickling each other
and giggling
and I was like what is protocol here
like what is I actually in that moment I
was like what do you do course I
literally just pulled out my phone and
took a picture I have a picture
aha two feet away from the two of them
who are hugging and then they did this
cute they put us all on stage in a row
and and a crowd could ask questions and
they would say stuff like I remember
Bishop Dalai Lama turns the bishop to do
and looks at him and says have you
gained weight and then they would just
die laughing up and I was like oh
because in the alternative wisdom
tradition there is the wisdom of the
heaviness of life and we could all die
tomorrow we're barely hanging on we're
hanging on by a thread the whole thing
but if you actually enter all the way
into that the terror and fragility of
life you end up with if you push through
even farther what you arrive at is but
we're here today mm-hmm so we might as
well do something today yeah so what I
noticed is how many people had got to
the heavy the whole thing is falling
apart the system is rigged against us
let alone the EPA let alone industrial
farming and they parked themselves there
but if you keep going you get into this
other space of I know it is you're right
but we're here and we're breathing and
we're walking around so let's take a
crack at some of this stuff let's see
how many people we can get drinking
water do let's see if we can make some
difference and that person that person's
now actually dangerous hmm
cuz they're coming and that's why I talk
about it's almost bullet but you might
come a bullet per you become weirdly
bulletproof and I remember I remember
doing an interview 2012 ish was NPR and
they started quoting one of my critics
on the air and I remember for the first
time they got done quoting that critic
and instead of my usual well that guy's
a like instead of my lawyer
like okay I'm gonna make my case I'm
gonna do but I remember I just burst out
laughing and I was like that's the
critique I'll tell what that is that's a
nerf bullet and I started critiquing the
pratik with joy like that's it come on
come after with something more confuses
the whole thing that's all it come on
you can't make something like it was
just it became like play mmm
and that's not to negate the seriousness
it's just if you move into that space
now you actually are in the space first
off the ego has taken a proper backseat
and all the people I know who are
actually who actually are moving the
needle in some way they have like out
there's like they've tapped into a
there's some punk rock in there mmm-hmm
like I know we're similar in the system
cool huh mmm-hmm
when people I know who are organizing
themselves in some new political ways
they're they're all in there also
laughing the artists I know that the
doctors I mean the people I'm sure
you've seen that it draws you to them
because in some senses they're hearing
music and they're inviting you to dance
with them and it's just a fundamentally
different metaphor it's a different way
of seeing it well there's a strength of
that too yeah like it's a feeling of
like there's a there's a center of
gravity yeah it just feels like I'm past
like whatever that noises over there
like I'm cool I can be over here and
laugh like it's not affecting me right
that way right and you're not mocking
device not like you're not but all the
people like think of all the people
running small businesses who every week
is a grind can they make payroll can
they make if you can move into hey we
made another week check this out and now
you're really in the moment and now you
actually have a shot at joy and actually
part of it came because I was trained as
a pastor so at early 20s I got a job in
a church and one of the things that
happens as a pastor is people call you
when they're in a rough place and right
away like 24 25 I was doing funerals of
people who died of AIDS when no one was
talking about that or people would call
the church and say I'm about to kill
myself can I talk to a pastor so all
sudden my phone ringing I pick it up and
be like what if you were there's about
25 years I distinctly remember visiting
a guy in prison when I was 25 who was in
isolated lockdown because he was violent
and they led me in this little room and
said the
we'll be here in a moment and I was like
to the guard I was like where are you
gonna go and he's like well I'll you'll
be in here with the prisoner and then
all I was like where are you gonna be in
he's like I'll be out there and he
starts to lock the door and I was like
what happens if he tries to hurt me and
the guy was like the guard says I'll be
able to watch it on my monitor so I
would do or I remember going to the ICU
unit the hospital and visiting these
young families whose kid was in the
plastic clear plastic box and then I go
home to dinner with my family
and I would try to reconcile the
suffering because when you're a pastor
like the funeral they invite you you've
never met some of these people they
invite you to the funeral home to help
plan the funeral and you sit down and
realize all these people hate each other
and I'm supposed to somehow in the midst
of this death make an experience that
will somehow honor the person who died
information it was impossible situation
after impossible situation then I go
home to my young family for dinner and I
couldn't reconcile the suffering I was
seeing with the blessing and goodness of
my own life mm-hmm and it like broke me
the other way it was like oh the only
way to do this is to move to some place
of gratitude it's the only way I'll ever
survive is just but I do have today and
we are here and there is this thing
unfolding so let's watch it let's see
what happens and let's all witness to it
so some of this happened to the early on
out of great disruption and trauma
almost did you read the book of joy the
it's by Doug Abrams it's the story of
Bishop tutu and and the Dalai Lama like
getting together for no way Dalai Lama's
birthday do you read this book I know
what it is I love it
yeah and it's about their relationship
it's about their friendship and it's
about not only how they're able to
maintain that perspective of gratitude
and and levity in a world of suffering
but how you know we can all bring more
of that into our own life and it's a
little book it's easy to read or
whatever but you should check it out
that's something
on that cuz experiencing it up close I
was like it literally for me was a
transformative I am witnessing I think
I'm wanting to seem like the actual the
secret to the whole deal or the I think
I'm seeing how it actually works
yeah well the dynamic between them uh
because they're like little boys
absolutely like love each other deeply
and it speaks to a larger you know yes
perspective of how they navigate the
world yeah I did a podcast that I did a
podcast with Doug - you could listen
anyway all right so Andrew what like
what is your aspiration for the movie
like not like in terms of how many
people see it or whatever but like what
do you what do you what is your hope
that people take away from the
experience of watching the movie yeah
it's really interesting because I think
when when I'm when I make something it's
it's like it's very very personal to me
and I think part of why you saw me kind
of emotional at the premiere is these
things are very they're inextricably
linked not just to a season of my life
but they're they always have at the core
some question I generally don't know the
answer to when I come in you know it's
not just that I don't know is this gonna
fit together into a movie it's that I
don't know the answer like I'm looking
for something and so for eg I can look
back on each of the things I've made and
that's that's been true and so for me I
have this kind of profoundly
life-changing experience making this
film and it opens me up
it gives me keys to unlock doors that
have been locked several years ago and
in it it
yeah I'm just at the beginning of
figuring all this out but it it it's
inspiring on a very deep deep level to
me and so you have that experience and
then this week the film gets released
and it gets to go out there and I think
in some ways you want it to do for other
people what it did for you like I want
people to have the experience of of
having a two and a half three or
conversation with Rob and I and I think
the benefit of that is I want people to
feel less alone
I think there's millions and millions
and millions of people in this country
and
the world that were handed something
very reductive in the form of religion
oftentimes I think he did damage to
their personal psyche I think it
strapped them down with guilt and fear
and shame that they're still caring and
that they were made to believe if they
challenge that if they moved away from
that they were betraying something or
they were there was something broken
about them that's what I actually I
think there's guilt and shame that comes
into that yes I think for me a story
like this is you're not alone you're not
crazy the thing you've rejected you're
rejecting for a reason because it's been
bastardized and it's it's a horrible
cheap knockoff it's like in the dollar
store it's the little figurine it's not
the real statue so number one just know
that know that know that and then number
two perhaps you could open yourself up
to two leaning in and getting some of
the insight that some of these
traditions have brought us without
taking the whole thing you know like
when I was growing up it was like you
were given the whole package and it was
like take er leave everything sign on
the dotted line
yeah there's no ala carte no right no
there's nothing else I'll you're gonna
vote this is how you feel about this
issue because I mean that's like that's
that's on a personal level what I hope
people experience but I also think on a
very collective level I think what you
were just talking about Robin what
you're articulating rich is that sense
of not only do we desperately need
people to wake up we need people who are
going to be awake and alive and
available for the long haul and I think
I've even experienced that in my life
where it's like I've had that very
youthful you know I see an injustice or
I go experience something that really
rattles me and it's like you're just
swinging wildly at it you know you're
just swinging and it's just it's from a
very beautiful place but I think when I
look at someone like Rob honestly like
what someone like you rich I think like
I'm trying to set up my life in a way
and my family in a way so that I can be
someone that makes things that are
helpful for a long time that I can have
these experiences and they can I can I
can share them and I want to be doing
that when I'm 80 and I think that there
are certain tools
insights words poems prayers inside of
this big amalgamated thing we've called
religion that offer help to do them yeah
what I hear in that is is is this sense
of or I guess what I want to say is the
path to truly redressing what ails us
doesn't necessarily come in the form of
flyswatter to say scott pruett needs to
step down as head of the EPA what we
really need if we want to truly solve
these problems for the long term is to
raise consciousness fundamentally right
we need to raise the bar on our
awareness our connection with who we are
fundamentally as human beings and what
that means right spiritually emotionally
physically and Athiya really really
right that is the solution and it's
amorphous and it's confusing and
sort of unclear and at odds with kind of
the the forces of where our culture is
right now in this moment but ultimately
that's the path for well and that's like
I think that's beautiful and that's like
I think for me the realization that I'm
thinking a lot about right now is sort
of stepping back and realizing like we
have to get really honest about the fact
that all of the stories that we were
given to explain the world around us
were not created equally and some were
funded for certain reasons some were
designed for certain reasons and a lot
of fallout comes when we like have
leaned into a story thinking like the
story of American consumerism the
imagined wasn't designed with our
well-being at heart it wasn't designed
with the good of the planet at heart it
was designed to make more profit for
these types of you know so I think like
backing up from some of these stories
that we've lived inside of and sort of
saying in a whole new way how do we
write a story for the future that is
based on what we now know we need
globally and what we know leads to you
know human well-being personally that is
that's wildly different than the suicide
machine that we're living in especially
in this context in this country right
now it's not working it's hurting us
like it would be one thing if we were
ravaging the planet and dominating
entire groups of people and we were like
the happiest people on the planet but I
think you know image in the school
shooting I think what like gets to me
every time there's that like check on
like how unwell like how deeply unwell
we are is this sense of that is that's
coming at the cost of you have those two
parallel things our own personal
unhappiness as well as our own personal
sorrow as well as globally speaking so
yeah I think we need new tools I think
we need and we need to do we need to
look in new places I just I keep I keep
I remember that after the election in
the editor near Times he said what did
you learn covering this whole process
and he said we didn't take religion
seriously and we're gonna hire more
religion writers and it's not because he
was saying like religions done all this
good stuff for America is I think he was
saying these stories whether you like
them or not whether you believe in them
or not whether you think they're helpful
or harmful they have played a central
role but driving heartbeat it's the
driving heartbeat and so I think for me
it's like I hope people can look at a
film like this and say okay we need to
take seriously what this story has
brought about we need to be we need to
take seriously where we now find
ourselves as a result and we need to
pull out the good without sacrificing it
to a small minority that's tried to
claim the whole thing is theirs and and
do it not with a hammer but to use the
analogy or the metaphor that you that
kind of inner lineatus the movie it's
more like surfing right which is how the
movie ends spoiler alert right this idea
that you have to you have to ride with
the the sort of currents of culture and
delicately Coast it in order to you know
plant those seeds of renewal yeah yeah
incoming consciousness rises step by
step by step and the patience to under
and that when people are at a certain
place you don't skip steps so even for a
lot of people realizing maybe there's a
larger cat I've always voted Republican
maybe I shouldn't that's actually a
giant step forward or I should probably
eat less meat giant step for some people
and the maturity to know you affirm
movement wherever you see it you may be
way down the road but anybody anywhere
anytime ile ittle bit of movement you
celebrate it mm-hmm as opposed to the
arrogance of all if you were just caught
up to me then you'd be okay well a lot
so many so many well-intentioned
movements just hamstrung themselves for
yeah their inability to fan the tiny
flames of forward progress because right
it's not ideal or perfect
right right right as opposed to it's all
happening on the continuum and you you
cheer on anybody taking any step which
is the danger and when you don't when
you don't recognize what the story was
you repeat it so like I remember have an
experience which when I started into the
plant-based world and you know getting
into into some of the the vegan culture
and and I'd have these moments I was
like oh no this reminds me of
fundamental Christianity is very similar
well oh but you're doing that so you're
not this you know or you're doing it
wrong yeah we're just trading stories
rather than stepping back and saying
wait a second that I'm right you're
wrong
these this is my tribe that they're not
my step it's not serving us it's not
certified right you know all right
how long have been going for Oh even go
for a while I have to ask you Rob Rob Oh
Rob no I've closed my I haven't looked
at these at all that's like my security
blanket I have that brain fart and I
can't think of anything how does it feel
to have a movie out there called The
Heretic I've always chafed at the words
simply because I love my work I love
making things and the idea that somebody
somewhere doesn't like it it's like
no okay it's just always been like it's
not interesting to me and I was just
like no I've sort of fought against it I
sort of laughed the people use that word
because when somebody uses that word my
first thought is oh you just aren't
familiar enough with your own tradition
cuz nothing I'm saying is new and
actually Andrew calling the movie the
heretic it's like weirdly I've had to
sort of make peace mm-hmm with it you're
forced Ryan with firmly in mm in the
last scene an eight-mile when he takes
it all it just owns it and well if I
it's it's when he first call I was like
ah I don't like that word then I thought
man that is a badass thing to call the
movie yeah and and but also like who is
the real heretic here
what is heretic oh yeah and I think when
I realized what he was doing there is
he's like people call well how did it
happen you were you told somebody who
happens let's definitely click baby
listen to this
this race that's how I do everything
yeah I think that's quick baby yes I
always that lunch with I was back in
Atlanta where I grew up and I was with
someone and they were very um
it's a very conservative religious
little thing and someone asked what I
was working on I told her that I was
making his film about Rob Bell and she
like put her fork down and she was like
you know he's a heretic and in that
moment I was like thank you did you
respond to that
I've never responded I've just said yeah
yeah I just said okay I'm gonna make a
movie about it I mean it's like yeah to
me to me it's it's a it's actually a
powerful world kid it's a powerful word
because it's it's historically loaded
history hasn't always it's interesting
if you really parse through where those
people typically sort out now retro
actively and I just never have
understood why we value innovation and
change in Ford progress in so many
categories and yet when it comes to our
deeply most sacred held beliefs we don't
let them evolve with what we now know
about
the world and what we you know he's
saying like so to me it was just kind of
like insanity like when I was getting to
know Rob and like following the work I
was like the fact that that's the thing
that's being like wouldn't it be insane
not to question this stuff like I don't
I don't understand like yeah the same is
true with all this stuff the same is
true of a America that's a mystery it's
like a very small group people kind of
claim the moral high ground and they
they had they come to define like the
center of gravity as you mentioned gets
to define what is it unassailable so
then anyone coming up that hill and you
do I mean that with whether it's people
eating differently whether it's people
you are then labeled as the the on this
or the anti that or unpatriotic or
unchristian or a heretic or whatever and
I think that whole metaphor is broken
and I actually think that reveals itself
to be something actually there's a key
in there I really do think there's a key
in there because if you really look at
that thinking closely it's just so
dangerous and so flawed and history is
strewn with examples of when we've just
done groupthink and weave unquestioned
and power has just I mean like we don't
have to look that far back yeah no not
at all I would also say one thing about
the title one more thing it's humbling
because you have to make peace with how
people will respond to you and your work
in the world and the ego wants to
control the narrative the whole way
mm-hmm
but all you can do is do your work in
the world and then it will be understood
it will be misunderstood maybe
appreciate it it may be slandered
there's this deep peace you have to make
that you either stay on the couch and
you just become one more part passive
observer doing comments on YouTube you
know maybe yeah or you get in the game
and you get skin in the game and you get
a little bloody and you do your work
mm-hmm
and you you align your life around be a
part being a participant not an observer
and if you make that shift if you cross
over into that
then there's a good chance some of what
you do will be misunderstood or you may
get get rocks thrown at you or well yeah
I mean the trope is anybody who's ever
done anything
yes exactly exact reversal it's like you
can't have exactly other and and if you
can make peace with that on the front
end mm-hmm
then now you have a shot at joy mm but
if you're constantly letting that
determine your joy it'll always be an
elusive man on a non attachment right oh
and today you know Andra asked you like
what is your aspiration for audiences
you know what kind of experience you
want them to have with this movie on
some level you have an intention and a
point of view but you have to detach
from that experience because they're
gonna have their own experience and
that's gonna be what its gonna be right
and there's there's something beautiful
about that but there's also something
that that provokes that like sense of
wanting to control the story right
totally well I think about as you're
saying like how you want to control the
whole story which is I laugh you saying
that and then you let someone make a
document ya know creative control but
also it would have been weird if you
were like okay we'll do this but I get
to like you know craft it yeah but I rob
they'll want to do like that yeah but be
like oh this is just being driven by the
ego it can't be that way right right
it's this is a much better story yeah
cool all right well we got to wrap it up
thank you thank you thank you for having
us I love both of you guys I love you
too man I would love you man I love
coming to your house thank you love
seeing you love the movie you did an
amazing job
it's a courageous work and I was honored
to be at the premiere to experience it
with an audience for the first time and
and I won't like rain my neck a few
times to see how Rob was doing you're a
pretty good poker face throughout but I
really enjoyed it and I can't wait for
the world to embrace what you guys
worked so hard to create I wish you well
and I want to know what's what's next
what are you doing Andrew you got a new
movie you're working on
gonna be predictably tight-lipped um
yeah I I am but only because I don't
know I sort of have this thing where
these things work sort of one at a time
for me and I I think we're finishing
this now and then the next thing will
will open up I stressed out for a long
time about that I have a lot of friends
who can make like seven things at one
time and they're so productive for some
reason I just it just works in this way
and I remember is right about this time
where we have finished the true cost and
Robin I met and started talking so I'm
open right now I'm kind of like excited
because it always there's something new
that always comes up right now so I'm
not telling you not because there is
something in know but you you're not
actively like I need my next project
like you're somebody who waits for the
inspirations but these things are too
long and too difficult to only kind of
be interested I like for me as a person
I I don't know I just have my one way of
doing it it's just kind of like heart
soul body I just like viscerally have to
be chasing after something and that um
yeah I I trust that that will happen
again I love these I love doing this I
like I I it is intoxicatingly fun to
make this and I'm thinking even as we're
having a conversation it's just making
me realize like what uh what a gift it
is so every time we get to do it it's
just kind of like whoa we got to do that
again that's super cool what about you
Rob your touring yeah taurine I think
we're about to announce another couple
legs so I'm through the end of the year
so probably coming to a city near you
good listener and then there's always a
new teaching for the Rob cast so let's
come out on Monday it's my podcast and
then other stuff that I like yeah very
excited about I don't like to let it out
till it's ready yeah just bring it up
boy you always say it like if somebody
says well what do you do you're like I
make things yeah your little stuff back
house making yeah there's some good
stuff brewing right now it's fun cool
all right so the movie is available on
Amazon and iTunes worldwide worldwide
right mostly we're working towards
worldwide it's a lot of places yeah
there's like a few countries that keep
emailing but we're working on right all
right should be easy to find for most
people out there and if you want to
learn more about Rob Rob Elcom all his
dates and all his good stuff all his
school you can download something to say
you're on the Radiohead model right like
yeah oh yeah right pay what you want pay
whatever you want and until next time
gentlemen yes you should we go eat some
food
like anything Rob will you take us out
the way that you end the Rob cast oh
yeah yeah yeah and my brothers my rich
roll brothers and sisters may grace and
peace be with you every step of the way
be some plants
[Music]